(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar um pouco sobre o uso-capião.
O uso-capião é um direito no qual alguém que exerce a posse sobre determinado
imóvel, como se fosse dono daquele imóvel, pode pleitear a propriedade daquele
imóvel.
E aí, se ele preencher os requisitos da lei, ele vai ser o novo proprietário
daquele imóvel.
Existem alguns tipos de uso-capião com alguns prazos diferentes, dependendo do
tipo de imóvel, da metragem do imóvel, e isso aqui não é o objetivo do curso.
Não adianta eu passar aqui esses prazos pra vocês, porque o que eu quero falar
é você, como interessado em arrematar, você deve pesquisar quem está ocupando
aquele imóvel.
Se for o devedor ou a família do devedor, se for um inquilino, tudo bem, você
pode seguir com aquela arrematação.
Agora, se na sua pesquisa sobre quem está ocupando um imóvel, você se deparar
com a informação de que quem está ocupando é um invasor, você não deve nem
continuar analisando a documentação daquele leilão.
Você deve partir para o próximo leilão.
Então, não interessa se aquele invasor está lá há um ano, dois anos, cinco
anos, isso interessa pra ele saber se ele tem direito ou não a uso-capião.
E ele precisa saber disso.
Você, como interessado em arrematar, você tem que pegar os imóveis que vão te
dar menos trabalho.
Você deve pegar aqueles imóveis que vão ser mais simples, que é quando está
morando família do proprietário ou próprio proprietário, que é quando está
morando um inquilino, isso tudo é fácil de resolver.
Se você se deparar com uma informação de que é um invasor, nem tente pesquisar
qual é o prazo que aquele invasor está ali, se ele poderia ou não já requerer
um procedimento de uso-capião.
Cai fora desse leilão e parte para o próximo leilão.
Não fica com o pensamento de que, ah, eu soube que o invasor só está ali há um
ano e para aquele imóvel específico o prazo de uso-capião seria cinco anos,
então tá tranquilo, eu vou arrematar aquele imóvel e depois eu tiro aquela
pessoa.
Não, porque você não tem como confirmar se realmente aquele invasor ele só está
ali há um ano.
Pode ser que ele tenha como comprovar que ele está ali há bem mais tempo, que
ele já teria direito a requerer uso-capião.
Então, se você se deparar com essa informação de que quem está ocupando o
imóvel é o invasor, deixa aquele imóvel de lado, parte para o próximo leilão.
E existem casos que você, ao analisar a matrícula, já vai constar lá a
informação de que tem um processo de uso-capião em andamento.
Você também não deve participar desse tipo de leilão.
Deixe esse leilão para outra pessoa ou até mesmo ninguém vai arrematar esse
imóvel de leilão.
Você não deve participar quando tem um invasor, nem tente descobrir qual é o
prazo que aquele invasor está ali.
Se se deparar com a informação de que é um invasor, já parte para o próximo
leilão.
Tem leilão todo dia, como eu sempre falo, você deve participar dos que vão ser
mais fáceis de legalizar a documentação, de desocupar.
Esse leilão que tem um invasor, ele não é tão fácil assim de realizar a
desocupação dele.
Então, parta para o próximo leilão.